[Musique]
marie marc ysaye camboulit et stéphanie
chaudron font la paire une complicité
professionnelle qui leur permet de
cogérer leurs classes chacune référente
d'un niveau mais les enseignantes
accompagne l'ensemble des élèves de la
maternelle du coup elles échangent
beaucoup d'entre elles y compris pendant
la pause de midi
cette mise au point qu'on fait
régulièrement ça nous donne aussi un
recul une analyse et je trouve que on
passe plus vite à autre chose on va tout
à l'essentiel je dirais on est toujours
aiguillé par le regard de l'autre même
si on a besoin de communiquer peut-être
plus qu'ailleurs on gagne du temps sur
l'organisation qui est toujours
communaux de classe
c'est bien de la t2c sur ok d'accord
pensé bon passer d'un accompagnement
individuel à un travail collectif par
niveau cette adaptation permanente est
une des clés du projet on est au service
de l'enfant ont l'accompagnant n'est
plus le maître qui
les maquis contrôle et qui
managent la classe on n'est plus au
service de l'enfant au service de ses
apprentissages au service de ses progrès
et on s'adapte complètement à l'enfant à
sa son individualité donc c'est la
posture est complètement différente
[Musique]
moi je me sens maintenant être intégré à
leur niveau je me sens plus être celle
qui détient tout le savoir est qui qui
va faire un an matériel n'a pas de cours
magistraux mais c'est souvent comme
cette posture la de l'adulte qui disent
il faut faire qui explique et j'apprécie
plus être à leurs côtés et de faire avec
eux qu'il a vous jouez je jouais plus
des fois vous jouer ensemble les
enseignantes ont à coeur que les enfants
prennent confiance en eux se respecte
tout en respectant les autres c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est dans
les programmes mais je dirais que
peut-être le respect de soi c'est
peut-être pas mis en avant autant pour
nous c'est très important
d'apprendre à se respecter soi-même de
d'aller trouver en fait le bonheur en
soi et d'aller seront de se rendre
compte de tout ce qui est beau autour de
nous et en nous donc donc on fait
attention à nos émotions est ce que
c'est le rôle de l'école ben oui
bah oui bien sûr il y à il ya une vraie
reconnaissance des besoins de l'enfant
les neurosciences je crois qu'ils ont
vraiment ciblé mis en avant que l'enfant
avait besoin qu'on le considère qu'on
fasse attention à ces émotions je pense
que maintenant voilà ça a été mieux dit
et on peut mieux le prendre en compte à
l'école aussi de le faire la maternelle
condorcet et dans le quartier
prioritaire des orchamps palente juste
un chiffre 72 % des collégiens de ce
secteur sont deux milieux défavorisés
mon mari marc ysaye camboulit et
stéphanie chaudron leur projet pour une
école heureuse ajustements tout son sens
dans ce quartier
je suis une enseignante heureuse
benj depuis confesseur moi je viens à
l'école avec le sourire je viens détendu
je prends plaisir à ce que je fais et la
satisfaction aussi de voir des enfants
qui réussissent mieux parce que
je suis dans cette école depuis
longtemps et je connais bien ce quartier
et ses enfants et la problématique de
ces famille quand même qui sont pour la
plupart
dans des milieux et demandé dans des
situations assez difficile et les faire
passer au cp en ayant dit encore
beaucoup de lacunes c'était pour moi
difficile à vivre parce que là tous les
enfants réussissent à alors pire mois
ils réussissent tous beaucoup mieux
demain nous irons aux forêts les enfants
s'y rendent deux fois par mois